once again is a public service to this
year's Comic Con attendees here are some
panels this weekend that have very short
lines on Sunday there's learn which
Italian Renaissance artists almost
became Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles yeah
almost almost yeah there's yeah there's
what if Mark Ruffalo was from Buffalo
upstate New Yorkers discussed the
ramifications yeah there's I like this
one vroom-vroom a conversation between
Batmobiles yeah check this one out
Arthur Hemsworth a Regional Sales
Manager for Duane Reade reveals he's not
related to Liam Chris or Luc there's
this one check it out remember that girl
who went viral because she could run
like a horse meet her sister and then
there's mom took my boba fett out of the
box grief counseling for
obsessive-compulsive
we have these pop dolls you know that we
give away and out wait a minute every
year every year I come outside and
people have the pop dolls and they want
me to sign them you know yeah and I go
to sign they're like no not on the
window
well then there are other people there
like on the windows
[Applause]
just show baby okay either way in 20
years they're worth nothing
[Applause]